welcome back to the feed a world cup
presented by chess.com
round two is underway a lot of results
coming in but before we delve back into
the games
something funny was caught on camera at
the start of the round
in our producing team working so hard to
bring that to you let's watch so it's a
good view of the start of the round
uh the players are taking their seats
you can see uh in the front of your
camera there
cindarov has already taken a seat with
the black pieces and there comes ali
reza in the gray suit
okay we're about to number one we're
about to see a handshake oh
yeah okay let's play the play-by-play
watch what happens
a little mishap there as one side tries
to
high five the other with a handshake and
back and forth they go
a little bit of a mishap at the start of
the round
total miscoordination right happy